اقل من اسبوع يفصلنا عن قمه النيتو في
ليتوانيا وعلى عكس طموحات كييف لم توجه
لها الدعوه كامله وبدلا من ذلك تلقى
الدعوه دمزيه لحضور بعض الاجتماعات
الجانبيه امر اعتبرته اوكرانيا اساسا
بتضحياتها وهناك مفارقه اخرى ايضا الناتو
وصف قيمته المقبله بقمه تكرس الدعم لكيف
الدعم المتواصل الا ان اوكرانيا وصفتها
بالقمه التي تغرد خارج مسار التاريخ بل
ذهب وزير خارجيتها
ووصف تجاهل ضم بلاده بالانتحار اعضاء
النيتو سيعملون على توفير دعم اكثر من
لاوكرانيا وتحسبا لوصول ترامب في
الانتخابات المقبله وهو ما يضمن استمرار
غياب في خوض الحرب لاشهر اضافيه امر لم
يقنع كييف بالطبع كان صريحا وطالب بضمانات
كافيه من اجل دخول بلاده لليتو بعد
استرجاع اراضيها ليكون السؤال
ماذا لو وافقت قمه النيتو في ليتوانيا
الاسبوع المقبل على عضويه اوكرانيا
الكامله في حلف الناتو
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا لن تدخل عائله النيتو قريبا
والاولويه الان هي تقويه جيشها امام روسيا
في الوقت الذي طرح هجومها المضاد اسئله
كثيره امر غير مقبولنسكي من الشركاء الذين
يطالبونه بالصمود دون الاستعداد للدفاع
عنه يوما ما وامام استياء كييف يستعد
الناتو لتقديم عرض بديل ضمانات امنيه لكن
في اطار دول لا في اطار النيتو والحديث
هنا عن فرنسا باريس والمانيا الدول الثلاث
ستلتزم بتسخير قدراتها الوطنيه والجماعيه
لدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا واقتصاديا وسياسيا
ان تعرضت لهجوم روسي اخر عرض اخر امريكي
هذه المره واشنطن ستلتزم بالاستثمار في
الصناعات الدفاعيه الاوكرانيه ونقل
التكنولوجيا الحديثه لها لكن رغبه كياب في
عضويه الناتو تتعدى الضمانات الامنيه هناك
هدف مخفي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات